ça fait longtemps déjà
jeune-philippe est une jeune bénédictine
de 65 ans qui confectionne des chapeaux
mais sa principale passion reste avant
tout la chanson
auto compositeur elle a participé avec
succès à de nombreux radiochés en
famille ou sur les podiums Jeanne chante
sa joie de vivre
il se passe de moi
voilà ce que les coupes
cette coupe là voilà
il se coupe là cette année
et celle-là me l'a eu à bras fusée
c'est depuis à l'âge de 7 ans méchante
c'était dans l'Église c'est le père de
fait un concours
et puis le premier chanson la chanter
c'était le mariage de ma sœur et mon
avis de 13 ans et maman avait la chanson
mais sans faire connaître les options il
faut et après le jour du mariage est
arrivé devant la table devant la mariée
m'a chanté les gens ils comprenaient pas
ils croyaient pas si c'était moi
saventurer mais depuis méchante je peux
prendre des chansons des musiques des
autres faire des paroles par exemple tel
que chanson naamin handicap j'ai pris
j'ai dit
camarades
mais connait pas jouer la guitare
miam chanter mais passe-moi le temps
pour composer de la regarder je la
trouve à la mon vieux quand mes montures
podium toujours à micro dans mon main
mets-toi musique
ma famille l'a toujours gagné mais
est-ce que vous sont capables de
composer pour que les autres
pour moi mais peut faire mais il peut
faire la musique mais il peut faire les
peu Léa et mi peut composer aussi sur le
diamant comme ça voilà chanson telle
façon mais il peut faire aussi parce que
mes enfants jouaient de moi comme sa
maman mariage longtemps comment il fait
par ici par là-bas et ben maman l'a fait
chanson sur le mariage longtemps un Sega
sur le mariage de longtemps peut-être si
cela peut être ce sera ça
depuis longtemps
miam League
moi elle a fait une trop vieux pour moi
aller chante non radio
a les yeux
les
longues
après ça ça va voir comment tu
allô chanter
alors je rentre un petit Sega piqué
après
comment kiffer je l'attends pour
regretter
en ce moment
le gaz parce que
mais le premier tu es pas tellement bien
mais après ça
on a réussi à faire mais le chapeau
comment il sait faire c'est un chapeau
de maman que un chapeau de paille alors
moi la réfléchi me dit comme ça il faut
qu'au moins il fait ce chapeau là moi il
a pris le chapeau de paille voilà pour
ce tissu mon ami sur la table mon ami
dessus et puis voilà voilà ce que voilà
fait voilà ça c'était le fond du chapeau
tu es le bon chapeau et puis voilà pour
le chapeau moi la fait comme ça la
taille le bord comme ça
midi comme ça bien sûr ça ça doit faire
comme ça
pour la taille de bord
voilà
et puis voilà réfléchi on est à midi
pour le fond bien sûr ça doit faire
comme ça il doit prendre
ça la taille le fond comme ça là voilà
la taille de fond voilà ce que ça donne
ça c'est le fond
voilà le fond et puis pour le tour pour
le toit voilà pour papier ma taille
comme ça voilà
chapeaux des petits des gros
débats
de chapeau quand je vais à la fois je
mets mon chapeau à la fois
comme ça que il faut bouger il faut
parler dans un coin si votre nats par
exemple des chansons des autres têtes
des compositions à faire il faut faire
il faut pas avoir arrondir comme ça ah
mais il fait pas parce que les gens
vaillent à moi non il faut pas faire ça
il faut il faut enregistrer et créer à
ces outils qu'on écrit surtout il faut
écrire d'autres chansons s'il y a des
autres têtes
si on régisse et puis après quand tu
chantes tu essayes de répéter parce
qu'il faut parler aux autres coins vu
que vu que notre âge on a plus de temps
à vivre que il faut il faut y vivre
parce que moi mes prochaines des autres
que moi mis vive parce que méchante mais
bouge mais ça a des radios crochets les
jeunes de chanter ben c'est ça il
encourage à moi essaye de faire comme
moi parce que sinon tu fais comme moi de
m'avoir la joie de vivre de tout ma vie
bien avec beaucoup de bonnets à ce
camisa ce qui me fait la chanson il dit
quand je suis seul
j'ai pensé
à toi ma maman
je ferai donner les chansons que tu es
en pensant
à toi ma maman
je veux chanter pour toi maman
si c'est affaire c'est la fête de toutes
les
mamans et ton
cœur est en fait tu es entouré de tous
tes enfants
c'est une joie pour toi maman
maman
je vais chanter pour toi maman
bien mon énergie
le petit bouquet que vous la donne à moi
La Londe souviens